pas et maria pacôme et notre invité ce
soir voilà alors est-ce que astrid est
contente
astrid dix mois elle est contente et un
sourire à ce très irrationnel javascript
si je fais d'inscrits les comptes en
comptant la décorer ou bien alors vous
maria pacôme donc dans si vous n'êtes
pas comme est ce qu un diable vous êtes
là belle-mère foldingue quoi voilà une
fois de plus chiant tu ne chantes mais
pas folle dingue
pas folle la peine c'est une méchante
femme il réussit même pas sa belle-fille
l allure son peut même son le petit bébé
elle l'a dormait méchamment elle dit à
un moment oui bon ça va
faut pas faire chier un candidat aux
play-offs où elle est vraiment odieuse
vous êtes un petit peu quand même là la
barre joue dans ce film même s'il est
moins que que vous l'avez été oui j'en
étais là c'est d'ailleurs je vais
m'arrêter quand vous voyez c'est pour ça
que vous êtes devenu auteur c'est parce
qu'avant vous en aviez marre de faire ce
à quoi deux voilà j'ai compris que les
pièces que vous écriviez t'es pas pire
que celle qu'on vous apportait c'était
mieux
alors qu'ils avaient déjà il ya des
pièces bien meilleure mais apprend voyez
pas là et en plus vous avez découvert
que quand on touche les droits d'auteur
c'est plus sympa c'est surtout ça qui
était prêt à la grèce a été très
agréable très très agréable mais très
marias de bois de pognon
mais qu'est ce qu'ils racontent comme
imbécillité là où bien sûr que non je
vois beaucoup de ça vous avez de quoi
vous arrêter de travailler quand même
j'y pense à le sait comme l'a annoncé je
pense oui on va aller on va piquer ton
pognon mais en fait ce qui est terrible
et maria pacôme et ça arrive souvent
avec les avec les grands acteurs c'est
que vous avez été bon j'ai fait une
carrière formidable vous avez réjouit
nombre de fois et en fait votre rêve
secret c'était de jouer tchekhov cette
fameuse cette fameuse phrase que vous
adorez ne me secouez pas comme ça je
suis plein de larmes
oui dites le moi comme vous l'auriez 10
ne serait pas comme ça je suis plein de
larmes
ouais voilà ce qu'on a raté je fais
entre maria pacôme pendant la guerre
votre père était déporté à buchenwald et
l'époque vous êtes senti d'un seul coup
très seul trait libre et vous vous êtes
dirigés vers le vers le théâtre au cours
simon
vous dites plutôt café d'à côté
d'ailleurs la wii wii n'ont jamais été
une femme d'aider des cours je crois que
je me suis faite toute seule comme ça
alors simon au cours simon vous habitez
pas une beauté
mais entre garde vous dire quoi vous
aviez une présence oui c'est ça
av
foire
je vois je veux vraiment ces moustiques
je vois que tu es tombé sur le sur le
même plan
je viens de te soutenir ce qu'était un
peu seul ça va très bien oui toi aussi
un jeu te regarder à l'écran c'est bon
c'est bien mais à un moment donné c'est
pénible mais c'est un début de
l'émission ça va mais quand il va être
hui voilà matin voilà exactement c'est
que j'ai vu des trucs et je vous raconte
pas ce qu'on les prenne pas vu j'ai vu
monsieur de gaulle donc l'amiral de
gaulle un croisé gabriel cohn bendit
qu'abriel cohn bendit lui a dit bonjour
gabriel cohn bendit il a tiqué le viewty
ce qui est drôle c'est que c'est des
rencontres par procuration ouais c'est
assez l'heure d'hiver de cohn bendit
avec le fils de de gaulle oui voilà
c'est ça qui est marrant et lui il l'a
ticket enfin en fait donc son fils mais
non il a marqué le coup c'est rigolo
alors oui c'est que maria pacôme est
venu voter à temps la guerre son père
était déporté à buchenwald et qu'elle
allait au cours simon enfin plutôt à
côté du cours simon dans un district
s'appelle le village est alors si
mentalement c'est mieux en face d'accord
et simon lui a dit cette phrase
mémorable tu n'es pas une beauté mais on
te regarde ce qui veut dire que tout de
suite il avait vu que vous aviez une
présence quoi peut-être moi un peu pour
me flageller qui rajoute et n'est pas
une beauté
voilà ce fut dur ça peut permettre un
peu excessif il a dit waouh mais tu as
une présence
maria un moment encore été de s'auto
flageller sabah ont pas l'âme d'un vrai
je suis d'accord quand même pas déconner
alors évidemment signée pas beaucoup
d'argent à l'époque et simon vous a dit
toujours lui le cours simon
tu peux pas payer mais tu as une gueule
tu ris talal a pas rajouté mieux il a
dit non parce que va dire tu n'es pas
une beauté larry tu vas pas belge et
donc ne sera pas une bouteille tu vas
pas pêcher ta gueule tu restes tu vois
il avait je crois qu'il avait confiance
en moi même si oui que je travaillais
pas beaucoup il a dit tu restes un
direct et vous êtes resté je suis parti
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque vous aviez pas
beaucoup d'argent vous étiez soutien
continu non mais c'est vrai qu'à 16 ans
à 16 ans sérieusement mariée à 16 ans
vous étiez apprenti chez un fabricant de
chaussures oui mais bien sûr j'ai très
mal en pis arpète à feu - la wii enfin
que je viens travailler parce que papa
était dans les deux camps on était tout
jeune frère et moi et que fallait voilà
il a fallu temps et c'était un peu dur
mais séduire pour plein de gens ouais et
c'est l'époque où maria pacôme mon cher
moustiques étaient donc mancka vous et
des photos publicitaires et à ce moment
là donc j'étais pas belle les maillots
de bain et c'est d'époque on peut le
dire je crois ce soir parce que la
prescription
vous avez failli un peu mal tourné à
l'époque non oui oui c'est une présence
j'étais le fait que mon père était
arrêtée on était des mômes et que
c'était un homme très sévère le fait
d'avoir cette liberté du jour au
lendemain et est dangereuse parce que
parce que d'avoir j'étais très très bien
élevés mais très durement partir de là
voilà et maman était un peu faible
voilà donc j'ai eu la chance c'est de la
chance le théâtre le théâtre vous a
sauvé d'une vie dissolue maria pacôme je
sais mes rencontres m'ont sauvé crois
beaucoup plus à entendre le théâtre au
nord et puis voilà cette histoire de
soutien de famille a duré toute votre
vie parce que vous avez toujours été
ensuite celle qui a porté le fric à la
maison voilà oui évidemment ça vous
amener à accepter des rôles qui était
pas obligatoirement ce que vous espériez
étant adolescent
tenez vraiment pas bon du tout de ce que
j'ai joué à jamais une chose honteuse
dans mais vraiment quand tu t'es
vraiment trop moche je disais non je ne
sais pas j'ai jamais eu
je n'étais pas habité par le théâtre
j'ai jamais eu très envie
j'aimais bien j'aime bien écrire je veux
bien jouer j'aime bien la vie surtout si
tôt que j'avais gagné un que je gagnais
fric j'arrêtais très vite d'ailleurs et
je parte là-bas que je foutais le camp
je dépense mon fric et je revenais mon
agent me dit toujours mais tu feras
jamais de carrière mais je m'en foutais
moi et j'avais là cette chance
extraordinaire de retrouver tout de
suite quelque chose à faire est ce que
vous pensez sérieusement maria pacôme
que vous avez eu la carrière que vous
méritiez a tant donné flemmarde quand je
le suis et qui ont eu c'est vraiment
c'est incohérent la manière dont je vis
c'est une suite une brèche enceinte je
mérite pas cette carrière je méritais
pas mieux je regrette mais moi moi je
regrette de pas avoir fait du cinéma
mais avoir été voir des metteurs en
scène et fallait il faut le faire c'est
sûr elle s'est déplacée j'ai jamais rien
fait tout ce qui m'est arrivé c'est
arrivé et je crois que j'ai du talent
c'est pour ça donc ayant des qualités
bon ben j'ai surnager maria pacôme
en tout cas je sais pas si tu le sais
maria pacôme a été mariée avec maurice
ronet savez ouais tu aimes le plus beau
de tous n'étant pas une beauté c'est une
chance car j'ai pu avoir le plus bel
homme de cinéma et on était très
amoureux et yosseftal été écoutés on
était drôlement mignons tous les deux
étaient dingues de vous maurice ronet
vous imaginez le nombre d'oiseaux qui
sont jalouses de vous ce soir
alors ce qui est très marrant c'est qu'à
l'époque bonjour jamais imaginé ça l
époque où vous étiez avec maurice ronet
vous étiez un peu baba cool avant
l'heure quoi vous êtes parti dans le
bouddhisme zen on a fait des choses
insensées ont été mitigés retrouver à
moustiers sainte marie ils ont trouvé la
la la la la vieille terre pour refermer
on a fait des choses dingues on
abandonnait tout ce qui était théâtre
c'est fou c'est fou on n'était pas là on
était tout un groupe là il y avait des
gens même un peu qui après peintre tout
ça on est le cas c'était bien loin on
voulait une autre vie vous rêviez d'une
autre vie et moi j'ai commencé à être un
peu connu j'avais 33 non encore un petit
peu ça m'était complètement égalerait
j'avais envie de bouger de faire des
choses c'est vrai que ça s'est terminé
en vendant de la lavande au bord des
routes en effet toute mignonne à la wii
avec une amie on avait j'avais ma tâche
et des morceaux de 2,2 de tissus comme
ça que tout à l'heure on éteignait
toutes les couleurs on s'est dit que moi
c'était très adroit pour faire ça on
cueille de l'avant non tu parle pas du
tout bronzé avec la les deux jusqu'ici
et puis on arrêter les voitures ça c'est
un fric fou avec sa main on faisait des
trucs comme ça pour eux parce que c'est
mama cool avant la wii
ouais alors messieurs les moins souvent
je compare michèle laroque à elvire
popesco parce qu'elles sont roumaine
toutes les deux mais je crois que
j'aurais pu aussi vous comparez à maria
pacôme michèle laroque